y la pregunta más importante que
buscamos en el internet es definir la
humanidad y cuando me metí a buscar
definiciones encontré tantas que no me
podía quedar con sólo una así que les
dejo con dos de mis favoritas que las de
unido en un solo espacio y la pueden ver
atrás mío pero lo más importante de
estas definiciones me gustaría que los
lean y que piensen de verdad si en algún
momento ustedes han podido ver ejemplos
de altruismo de afecto de compasión de
arte en el mundo digital de esta
humanidad que tenemos definida
de las redes sociales actualmente están
pasando por un momento en el que la
gente dice que son las culpables de que
nos hemos deshumanizado y la gente está
con miedo pero es porque actualmente
está pasando algo que jamás ha sucedido
en nuestra historia y es que podemos
oírnos los unos de los otros antes en
los medios de comunicación no podíamos
escuchar lo que quería decir tu vecino
lo que podía decir no sé un primo o
alguien que ni siquiera conocidas en el
otro lado del mundo y qué es lo que pasa
todos están expresando apatía todos
están siendo extremadamente fríos y eso
nos asusta entonces son las redes
sociales verdaderamente las que están
causando esta deshumanización esta
apatía o quizás ya existía y
sencillamente las redes sociales están
poniéndolo en evidencia quiero que vean
atrás mío para que tengan una idea de
cómo ha sido todo este cambio que ha
habido en la comunicación a través de
los años
uno de estos cambios se dieron sin
resistencia actualmente estamos teniendo
un momento de resistencia a un cambio
muy fuerte tecnológico en como nosotros
nos estamos hablando si ustedes ven
estos iconos capas no muchos de aquí
pero algunos despidos reconozcan ahí sí
quienes en estos sólo los primeros
charlas que salieron al mundo digital a
través de los cuales yo la verdad pasada
metida y mi mamá alojaba y cuando mi
hermano pasada en el teléfono era peor
de sí hay mis épocas en realidad
salíamos en jerga y nos veíamos
personalmente que de esto de sobre el
teléfono y este sitio y si es que no mi
abuelito a seguramente salía con alguna
cosa como en mi época nos mandamos
cartas y lo decía en una manera muy
nostálgica porque como no querer
muchísimo a la manera que tú te expresas
en el día a día
pero esto obviamente va a tener una
resistencia a mí no me gusta que me
cambien ni siquiera lo que desayuno en
la mañana peor no me va a gustar la
manera en la que me comunico con otras
personas obviamente yo voy a tener una
resistencia pero porque se hicieron las
redes sociales esa es una de las partes
más importantes que habría que definir
las redes sociales se hicieron para
conectarnos para darnos una voz
el problema es que no todos están usando
esa voz de la manera en la que estaba
entendida la red social por si acaso
para todas las personas que dicen ahí yo
no uso redes sociales y usas whatsapp
si usas skype si usas lint en cualquiera
de estas redes son redes sociales no
estamos hablando ahorita solo de
facebook ni de instagram las redes
sociales abarcan muchísimo más que solo
esto
ustedes seguramente han escuchado de un
estudio súper famoso del doctor jan börn
que lo hizo en strip y él básicamente
dice que no podemos tener más de 200
conexiones reales en una sola vida
reales de apoyo
yo creo que muchas de esas conexiones se
pueden dar en el internet yo no veo
porque todas tienen que ser solamente
físicas
qué pasaría si mañana nos quedaríamos
con la posibilidad de tener tan solo
estas 150 o 200 personas en un grupo de
facebook o en un grupo de whatsapp o
suscriptores en youtube nos quitaría
muchísima libertad de expresión nos
quitaría muchísima libertad de en
realidad decir lo que queremos decir y
que la gente nos oiga como el caso de
todos somos marta ya que todos estamos
muy familiarizados con este caso que en
realidad fue muy fuerte fue un caso que
atacó completamente la humanidad de una
mujer y a través de las redes sociales
tuvimos el poder
de desarrollar empatía de apoyarla de
estar ahí para ella pero eso muy
difícilmente habría sucedido sin el
mundo digital que tenemos actualmente
otro punto muy importante y que a veces
es súper fácil olvidarlo porque vivimos
en una burbujita en nuestro mundo
individual
es el tema de la gente que quizás no
está socialmente cómoda la gente que
está socialmente en realidad
discapacitada
y yo les voy a dar el ejemplo en
particular de mi hermana mi hermano
tenía epilepsia desde muy pequeños tuve
un golpe en una parte de su cerebro hay
más de 100 tipos de epilepsia en el caso
de él él no podía en realidad conectar
con gente se ponía súper súper nervioso
al punto en que le daban crisis o sea se
ponía tan nervioso porque aparte había
tenido momentos de humillación porque la
gente se da cuenta que era diferente
y el paso súper solo durante muchísimo
tiempo pero qué pasó fue muy bonito
cuando salieron las redes sociales y yo
podía ver como mi hermano florecía
porque le veía de repente sentado
hablando con un millón de amigos y yo
con ganas tengo un nuevo amigo y se
ponía súper súper contento y eso no está
mal porque había gente que llegaba decía
ay christine a su hermano a través de
está en el internet otra vez está
hablando con gente que ni conoce eso no
es real
quiénes somos para decidir si esa
conexión es real o no era mejor la
alternativa de que se sienta solo
otro punto super importante es el tema
de la migración mundial en mi caso yo me
fui a los 18 años y viajé por todo el
mundo creo que mis papás a veces ya ni
sabían dónde estaba pero al principio
tengo 93 años pues acaso yo sé que soy
traer años pero tengo 33 años pero al
principio cuando yo viajé no habían
todas estas facilidades y avisa me
dificulta muchísimo esta comunicación
con mis padres porque ellos eran anti
tecnólogos pero completamente odiaban la
tecnología tenía que escribir cartas y
esto fue hace unos 15 años más o menos y
cuando salió skype en particular fue lo
máximo porque de repente ya podía hablar
con mi mamá podía hablar con mi papá
podía hablar con mi hermano no me perdía
de momentos importantes y esto fue
sumamente importante para el mundo
actual porque ahora ya no es que ya no
tenemos las líneas de antes de entre
países somos un mundo globalizado somos
un mundo que se está nutriendo cada vez
más entre culturas estamos compartiendo
conocimiento
y las redes sociales eso no sería lo
mismo pero la gente que ahora viaja qué
pasa se le está disipando ese dolor tan
fuerte que puede sentir el rato que
viaja que se va de su casa que se va de
su país porque al final del día yo sí
creo que la parte básica de nuestra
humanidad es nuestra familia el
siguiente punto del que quiero hablar es
del amor
el amor en pareja en particular
yo creo que el amor en pareja es algo
que buscamos desde siempre
muchas personas a veces quizás tienen un
poco de dificultades en encontrar esa
persona con la que quieren estar porque
no está en su entorno inmediato porque
en realidad esa persona no está dentro
de su contexto social no es una amistad
de una amistad o un conocido de un
conocido y por qué limitarnos en
realidad en este hoy en día algo físico
ya no necesitamos hacerlo no sé por qué
hace no mucho tiempo inclusive era tabú
decirle conocí a mi novia online
de hecho entre el año 2008 y 2012 el 35
por ciento de los matrimonios de eeuu se
conocieron en el internet
me gustaría que vean este vídeo atrás
mío que está pasando de una chica que
está clavando su rostro directamente un
pan y seguramente no van a entender de
qué se trata
ellos soy llama albert facebook se
mantiene anónima es una chica que en
realidad
[Música]
siempre tuvo un gusto super peculiar por
tocar la comida era un gusto táctil que
ella siempre tuvo desde muy pequeña y
cuando les compartió a sus amigas se
rieron don't know de una manera
humillante sencillamente le causa dobles
causado gracia que decidió abrir un
canal de youtube donde ella podría
exponer este sentimiento que le nacía de
no saber no sabía dónde y hacer que la
gente conecte con ella a través de la
risa porque esa también es una parte
humana muy muy linda nuestras los
sentimientos y la risa que linda qué es
encima de ese vídeo van a ver una foto
que representa la sexualidad en el tema
de la sexualidad también es súper
importante así como este es casi un
fetiche el tema del pan hay gente que en
cambio nace en el pueblo incorrecto la
ciudad incorrecta del país incorrecto el
lugar con la religión predominante que
sencillamente no quiere ver más allá de
lo que de lo que tiene en sus tres
metros de distancia y hace que la gente
no quiera auto aceptarse por quiénes son
les dificultan el que se acepten como
ellos quieren expresar inclusive su
sexualidad y qué es lo que pasa con el
internet te encuentras con gente igual
que tú que te hace darte cuenta que en
realidad no eres un raro
y temporeras
aquí también hay una foto de un mujerón
que de hecho la conozco es su mujer o yo
soy alta pero a mí me lleva como dos
cabezas
y jim no sólo nació en el cuerpo
incorrecto pero también en la ciudad
incorrecta ella nació en canadá en una
ciudad super chiquita donde pensaríamos
que enrollarla gente súper abierta pero
no lo era la gente le criticaba
muchísimo era súper humillada cuando
estaba en el colegio era un niño
y abrió un canal de youtube y abrió un
fabuloso canal de youtube yo la veo todo
el tiempo donde expuso todos sus
sentimientos y a través de la comunidad
que tanto le apoyo todos los días en el
mundo digital encontró el valor de hacer
su cambio de género
qué rico poder ser tú
aquí les tengo otro ejemplo muy
importante que es el del arte el arte
siempre ha sido una parte muy importante
de quienes somos nosotros en nuestra
base humana particularmente las redes
sociales han ayudado no solamente a que
artistas al estilo de por ejemplo
actores o músicos o muralistas puedan en
realidad tener un fin de lucro del cual
no dependen de otra persona sea nacional
diarios pueden vivir de su arte sin
tener que exponerse a que un agents o
que una agencia les diga no no tu
talento no vale en el internet todo es
válido ya mientras tú tengas la pasión
mientras tú sepas quién eres y te guste
nadie te puede decir nada
el siguiente punto super importante para
mí es el de atención consciente y yo
estoy súper consciente de que el
internet y las redes sociales no son
perfectas todavía hay muchas cosas que
tenemos que indagar muchísimas cosas que
tenemos que quizás cambiar pero más que
nada lo que hay que cambiar es el mal
uso de las redes sociales porque el
problema no son las redes del problema
son las personas el problema es que la
gente es olvidado la raíz y es para
conectar si nosotros empezamos a usar
las redes sociales con más atención
consciente que es en realidad una
técnica que la mayoría de psicólogos nos
van a decir que usemos para
desconectarnos del celular
pero si usamos la misma técnica para
pasar nuestro tiempo de internet con más
atención con más propósito con más fondo
qué pasaría mañana
y yo me siento súper afortunada porque
soy milán ya al ser millennial
siento que tengo como un músculo que no
tienen las nuevas generaciones porque yo
viví antes y después de las redes
sociales entonces es como que yo inti
intuitivamente sé cuando es hora de
desconectarme o ya llegó un punto del
río ya ya ya fue ya está demasiado
tienes para desconectarte vamos a la
vida real las nuevas generaciones no
tienen estos códigos y necesitamos
desarrollar los necesitamos ayudarles a
encontrar ese balance muy importante
también dejar de comunicar no sólo con
emoticones y encontrar más fondo
les dejo un vídeo que a mí sencillamente
de mesa sin sonidos y pasiones
ahora vamos a ver
si realmente los discapacitados nos
salimos mucho esto porque la mayoría de
los lugares no están habilitados creo
que ese es el vídeo más serio que ha
tenido mi canal estoy muy enamorada de
una chica strickler ser entrenada
sintiéndome como deslegitimada
y no quita que no pueda cumplir su sueño
y que sea un egoísta
y qué hacemos como rescatamos la
naturaleza humana de las redes sociales
hoy les tengo un manual de un minuto
punto número 1 y número 2 aléjate del
ruido digital y determina una base que
engrane con tus valores de qué es lo que
buscas de las redes sociales entra con
propósito no entres solo porque es una
rutina 2 no asumas que sabes algo sobre
alguien para sobre ello juzgarlo toda
esta gente que sale el internet a hacer
tantas cosas tan maravillosas no salen
para ser juzgadas salen para expresarse
y para aceptarse de una manera súper
pública y eso toma mucho valor
humaniza conecta y sobre todo empatiza
sin la empatía es extremadamente difícil
que conectemos entre seres humanos
y para eso son las redes sociales para
conectarnos entre seres humanos
punto número 5 prende tu wifi interno y
aplica atención consciente a tu tiempo
digital empieza a darte cuenta de todo
lo que estás haciendo en todo ese tiempo
punto número 6 generaría logos más allá
de un emoticón súper importante
el punto número 7 es mi favorito trata
sobre poneros y tratemos todos en
realidad es sobre poner porque a veces a
mí me cuesta sobreponer nuestras vidas
al mundo digital si es que tú vas a
contestarle una persona algo feo o
quizás no algo feo pero algo fuerte
sobre ponte y piensa si esta persona
estuviera frente a mí aquí físicamente
yo tendría esta actitud si la respuesta
es no no lo hagas
8 olvidas los retratos de la perfección
y está en la valentía de ser tú mismo y
9 mide tu dosis y aprende a saber cuándo
es el momento de desconectarse
así que la pregunta más importante
quizás no es y las redes sociales nos
están deshumanizando quizás la pregunta
más importante es a dónde nos está
llevando todo esto muchas gracias
[Aplausos]